la séance est reprise
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur les
conclusions du rapport commercial
extérieur l'urgence d'une stratégie
publique pour nos entreprises
je vous rappelle que dans ce débat le
gouvernement aura la faculté si le juge
nécessaire de prendre la parole
immédiatement après chaque orateur pour
une durée de 2 minutes et l'orateur
disposera alors à son tour du droit de
répartie pour une minute
monsieur le ministre vous pourrez donc
si vous le souhaitez répondre après
chaque orateur une fois que celui-ci
aura retrouvé une place dans l'hémicycle
et la parole est tout d'abord aux
orateurs de la délégation sénatoriale
aux entreprises qui a demandé ce débat
et le premier orateur c'est Monsieur
Vincent Segoin au nom donc de la
délégation sénatoriale aux entreprises
pour 4 minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
heureux que ce débat sur le commerce
extérieur puisse avoir lieu car il nous
paraît essentiel de ne pas répéter des
erreurs du passé la plus importante
d'entre elles fut le choix de la
désindustrie les actions pourtant
assumer par les gouvernements successifs
depuis des décennies personne n'a
anticipé les conséquences de ce choix
désastreux qui est à l'origine déficit
abyssale de notre balance commerciale
pour de nombreux commentateurs nous
avons touché le fond ou plutôt la bise
en dépassant la barre des 64 milliards
de déficit en 2022 évidemment les
dernières crises ont encore davantage
creusé le sol des échanges de biens
notamment à la veclaus du déficit
énergétique
mais cette dégrade d'action
conjoncturelle ne fait que renforcer une
tendance structurelle observée depuis 20
ans la situation est grave parce que
nous nous sentons impuissants face à
détérioration conjoncturelle du commerce
extérieur de la France n'ayant plus de
réserve pour faire preuve de résilience
elle est grave car notre premier
partenaire commercial l'Allemagne peut
au contraire résister à la crise
actuelle en effet en 2021 l'affichait un
solde positif de 178,4 milliards d'euros
selon Eurostat nous n'avons pas su tiré
les leçons des choix économiques ayant
placé nos deux pays sur des trajectoires
diamétralement opposés depuis des années
90 en termes de compétitivité et nous
sommes aujourd'hui les derniers de
l'Union européenne derrière l'Espagne la
Roumanie et même la Grèce
monsieur le ministre nous espérons
aujourd'hui que nous partageons le même
constat et les mêmes objectifs sur trois
points prioritaires le premier point la
team France Export née de la stratégie
dite de Roubaix de 2018 constitue un
indéniable progrès mais elle ne peut
être seule résoudre le problème du
commerce extérieur de la France car nous
ne pouvons pas changer la donne en nous
focalisant uniquement sur l'export
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des témoignages
de notre mission convergent autour d'un
constat d'une carence de vision globale
stratégique intégrant des objectifs en
matière d'importation
deuxième point réfléchir à une stratégie
en matière d'importation et de
relocalisation implique de s'interroger
sur deux éléments ce que nous sommes en
capacité de produire en restant
compétitif et ce qui contribue à notre
souveraineté les Français ont découvert
les conséquences des délocalisations de
production avec la pnurie des masques
pendant la crise du covid ils vivent
aujourd'hui dans l'angoisse de rupture
d'approvisionnement de médicaments
notamment pédiatriques on recense presse
de 320 médicaments thérapeutiques majeur
en forte tension
conséquence des localisation massive de
production nous ne pouvons plus attendre
les prochaines crises pour réfléchir en
relocalisation nous devons
impérativement nous demanderons nous
demander aujourd'hui quels sont les
dépendances qui peuvent porter atteinte
à notre souveraineté et en tirer des
conséquences en matière de
relocalisation
cette stratégie éminemment politique
devrait faire l'objet d'une loi
d'orientation économique pour la France
troisième point qu'il s'agisse de
relocalisation ou de réindustrialisation
verte nous ne pouvons plus nous voiler
la face rien ne sera possible sans
accompagner ce projet d'une stratégie
fiscale adéquate la force de frappe ce
sont les ETI or elles ne peuvent pas se
développer en France notamment en raison
d'une fiscalité de la transmission bien
moins favorable qu'en Allemagne ça fait
des années qu'on le répète
résultat nous ne comptons que 5400 ETI
contre 12500 chez nos voisins tous les
économistes ont reconnu que le poids de
la fiscalité de la complexité
administrative avait conduit les
entreprises françaises à créer des
filiales à l'étranger plutôt que
d'exporter et les importations des 46488
filiales françaises pèsent aujourd'hui
sur notre balance commerciale c'est
cette logique cette spirale infernale à
laquelle nous devons enfin mettre un
terme je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
alors la parole est à Madame Florence
blatrix compta au nom de la délégation
sénatoriale aux entreprises également
pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme le
souligné mon collègue Vincent Segoin
l'instant nous avons perçu tout au long
de nos travaux une défaillance en
matière de stratégie publique le
commerce extérieur doit être appréhendé
comme un écosystème et toutes les
dimensions de la compétitivité nécessite
que l'on se fixe des objectifs ambitieux
c'est vrai en particulier en matière de
compétence elle ne s'improvise pas et
sont incontournables pour que les
entreprises puissent s'emparer des
marchés étrangers compétences
linguistique économique mathématiques
doivent être renforcés pour accompagner
l'internationalisation de nos
entreprises les compétences sont
également au cœur de toute stratégie de
relocalisation voire de maintien dans
nos territoires des productions qui sont
aujourd'hui notre force prenons
l'exemple du secteur des services dont
les exportations ont augmenté de 142%
depuis 20 ans pour atteindre un sol
d'excédentaire de 50 milliards d'euros
en 2022 soit une hausse de 14 milliards
d'euros en un an ses services qui sont
intrinsèquement liés au bien industriel
repose aujourd'hui sur des savoir-faire
qui avec les nouvelles technologies
connaissent un risque non négligeable de
télémigration
cette fuite des talents est donc des
activités de service constitueraient un
revers fatal pour notre ici advenet
malheureusement or nous constatons à la
faveur des travaux en cours de la
délégation aux entreprises sur les
sujets de la formation des compétences
que les entreprises sont obligées de
s'organiser et de créer leur propre
école pour pallier les carences de la
formation initiale
comme l’ont démontré de nombreux
rapports de France stratégiques de la
Banque européenne d'investissement ou
d'autres l'indisponibilité de
travailleurs qualifiés constituent une
entrave à l'investissement et à
l'innovation monsieur le ministre il est
temps que la stratégie publique prenne
sérieusement en compte la question des
compétences pouvez-vous nous indiquer
comment vous organiser la coordination
des actions avec vos collègues en charge
de l'éducation nationale de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
formation professionnelle
la coordination au corps sera également
le maître mot pour appréhender les
enjeux de l'Union européenne nous savons
déjà que les surtranspositions
Françaises de directives européennes
constituent un handicap pour la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
mais sommes-nous réellement conscients
des effets des surtranspositions
européennes d'accord internationaux
ou bien du taux de recours dérisoire aux
instruments de défense
commerciale les IDC de l'Union
européenne par rapport aux États-Unis
lors d'un récent des bases sur les
conclusions du rapport de la délégation
aux entreprises consacrées à la RSE nous
avons souligné les difficultés liées à
l'absence de réciprocité énorme
applicable aux entreprises implantées en
de l'Union européenne et donc monsieur
le ministre comment la France
sensibilise-t-elle les autres États
membres de l'Union aux effets néfastes
de l'absence de clause miroir je sais
que c'est un débat qui est déjà porté
mais qui à mon avis mérite vraiment
d'avancer vous l'aurez compris l'enjeu
du commerce extérieur dépasse largement
la politique publique de soutien des
entreprises à l'export ce sujet ne sera
appréhendé efficacement que lorsque les
objectifs de compétitivité seront
déclinés dans toutes les politiques
publiques et partagées par tous les
ministères concernés nous espérons que
nos travaux trouveront en écho car nous
devons rapidement changer de logiciel et
définir ensemble les priorités de la
France en fixant un cap pour les 20
prochaines années je vous remercie
merci
alors dans la suite du débat la parole
est à Monsieur Thierry cosy pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 4 minutes chers
collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la France
subit depuis le début des années 2000
une détérioration continue de se balance
commerciale avec un déficit écrasant
évalué après 85 milliards d'euros en
2021 cette situation est
particulièrement inquiétante elle est
d'autant plus que la crise énergétique
actuelle est marquée par un grave
dysfonctionnement du marché énergétique
européen qui s'est traduit par une
envolée historique des prix du gaz et
d'électricité les dernières estimations
font état d'un déficit qui pourrait
atteindre plus de 150 milliards d'euros
il est nécessaire de trouver rapidement
une solution aux défaillance du marché
européen de l'énergie qui plombe
aujourd'hui la compétitivité de nos
entreprises et grève le budget de nos
services publics de nos collectivités et
de nos ménages
l'électricité que nous produisons en
France et portant l'une des plus
compétitives en Europe alors que la
spéculation se déchaîne sur les marchés
de gros nos entreprises et nos tissus
industriels ne peuvent pas directement
profiter de cette compétitivité si les
prix d'électricité n'ont de 16
d'augmenter on pourrait connaître une
nouvelle vague de délocalisation et des
industrialisations alors que dans le
même temps les États-Unis ont lancé un
programme protectionniste à travers
l'inflation l'inflation réduction actes
l'Europe l'Union européenne hésite
encore à protéger de manière vigoureuse
le peu qui lui reste de son industrie
sans un grand plan d'aide pour la
décarbonation de notre économie l'Union
européenne pèlera à atteint les
objectifs qui sont les siens cela
pourrait la placer à la merci du secteur
des nouvelles technologies dominées
principalement par les firmes
sino-américaines cela ne va pas dire
pour autant que le repli sur soi et la
solution l'Union européenne doit prendre
la mesure des phénomènes de reflux de la
mondialisation et adopter une approche
plus pragmatique et en phase avec les
enjeux de la transition écologique
nos dépendances aux importations
chinoises ne se cantonnent plus aux
produits de faible valeur ajoutée force
est constater que la Chine a désormais
investi un marché des produits de la
haute technologie
cette dépendance n'est pas spécifique à
la France elle touche aussi nos
partenaires européens et les États-Unis
lorsque la Chine a commencé à les
concurrencer sur des produits de haute
technologie les États-Unis ont réagi
auprès de l'OMC en dénonçant d'une part
l'utilisation du statut de pays en voie
de développement et d'autres parts les
nombreux subventions et protections que
la Chine déployées pour son tissu
industriel
comme par le passé les nations qui ont
le mieux tiré leur épingle du jeu sont
celles qui ont réussi à protéger leur
économie des règles du libre-échange
c'est ce méprendre que de continuer à
penser que l'on résoudra le problème du
déficit commercial en diminuant le coût
du travail cette course elle a déflation
salariale à maintes fois montré son
inefficacité elle serait d'autant plus
inopportune dans un contexte actuel de
retour de l'inflation d'origine
principalement énergétique la solution
pourrait être ailleurs les effets de
bord d'un capitalisme devenu incontrôlé
ont appauvri les couches populaires les
plus tributaires des secteurs
industriels marchands se faisant c'est
délocalisations ont sapé la confiance
collective envers les décideurs publics
et privés
cette confiance est pourtant primordiale
afin d'engager les nécessaires et
colossaux investissement que nous intime
d'engager le climat
sur le ministre je m'interroge le pacte
vert européen présenté comme une réponse
aux incursions protectionnistes de la
Chine et des États-Unis sera-t-il
suffisamment conséquent pour remettre
sur pied une véritable politique
industrielle capable de permettre à
l'Union européenne de gagner en
autonomie stratégique
rien n'est moins sûr pourtant le
gouvernement devra trouver rapidement
les réponses à cette question tant elles
conditionnent le retour à l'équilibre de
notre commerce extérieur
je vous remercie
merci
Monsieur ministre vous attendez juste
que notre collègue s'assied voilà
merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs bien sûr je partage avec vous
le constat de l'aggravation de notre
déficit sur la balance des biens qui a
plus que doublé par rapport à l'année
2021 ce doublement étant quasi
intégralement du en fait à la
dégradation de la balance énergétique
c'est à dire que nous avons sur 2022
était obligé parce que notre parc
nucléaire était en grande partie
indisponible du fait du rattrapage de la
maintenance que nous n'avons pas
effectué durant les deux années de covid
et donc au lieu d'exporter de
l'électricité nous avons été obligés
dans n'importe quel et nous avons
d'autre part subi de plein fouet comme
la plupart d'ailleurs de nos partenaires
la hausse des prix du pétrole et du gaz
qui sur l'ensemble de l'année
2022 ont été multipliés par 2,1 quand on
prend le gaz c'est 248% d'augmentation
donc nous avons cette situation très
particulière nous sommes confiants sur
le fait que elle va se résorber de
manière naturelle puisque le parc
nucléaire aujourd'hui qui a de nouveau
disponible à plus de 75 % et il le sera
encore davantage dans les prochaines
semaines nous sommes déjà redevenus
exportateurs d'énergie qui donc nous
exportons de l'électricité
ce qui est une bonne une bonne nouvelle
et puis pour le reste bien sûr nous
sommes en train d'agir au niveau
européen pour que les prix du gaz soient
capés et que le prix de l'électricité
soit recalculé selon une formule qui
permettent de rendre ces prix
acceptables au mégawater et donc je suis
confiant sur les efforts que nous
faisons avec nos partenaires européens
pour que l'Europe soit particulièrement
compétitive sur les prix de l'énergie ce
qui est évidemment une composante
importante de notre balance commerciale
merci monsieur Cosic non merci la parole
est à Madame Marie-Noël lineman pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste pour 5 minutes chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
rapporteur la chute de la balance
commerciale de la France est devenu
abyssale
elle se poursuit en dépit de discours
martiaux du président de la République
qui prétend que la réindustrialisation
du pays est en marche
ne nous laissons pas égarés par une
communication qui veut nous bercer de 12
illusions
la réalité que le compte n'y est pas et
qu'il faut changer de cap
car les faits sont têtus la part de la
production manufacturière dans le pays B
ne cesse de chuter
certes il avait déjà chuté jusqu'à 13,5
en 2019 comme vous le dites monsieur
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs il
n'est plus que de neuf pour cent
en 2021
notre pays est le dernier de l'Union
européenne à égalité avec la Grèce
oui la principale cause de la
dégradation du commerce extérieur et la
désindustrialisation
si ajoute certes désormais la forte
dégradation de la balance énergétique il
y a les hausses du gaz et de
l'électricité mais il y a le fait que la
France était redevenue importateur
d'électricité alors que jusqu'à présent
elle était exportatrice qu'on le veuille
ou non c'est la conséquence de choix
gouvernementaux qu'à la miteux depuis 10
ans
l'horizon est loin de s'éclaircir en
particulier
au regard de l'impact inquiétant de la
hausse des prix de l'énergie
42% des entreprises industrielles
estiment qu'ils vont doubler leur prix
d'énergie en dehors en 2023 et que la
prévision de cet effet c'est une baisse
de 1,5% de la production industrielle du
pays
et les propositions de mesure de
gouvernement ne sont pas de nature à
inverser la donne nous considérons qu'il
en faut davantage qu'il y a urgence
comme il y a d'ailleurs urgences de
s'exonérer de s'extraire de ces
dramatiques marchés européens de
leadership totalement absurde et
dangereuse
mais le cœur de la cible c'est quand
même la désindustrialisation
et nous partageons la proposition de des
rapporteurs d'une stratégie globale de
long terme pour le redressement du
commerce extérieur et la
réindustrialisation
mais pour ce faire faut partir d'un
bilan lucide et rigoureux
et ce bilan c'est difficile des
politiques développées par Emmanuel
Macron est largement soutenu par le
MEDEF
on nous disait plus la France pour que
la France retrouve sa compétitivité il
faut baisser le coût du travail
faut baisser les impôts
voilà 10 ans que cette politique dit de
l'offre est mise en œuvre 10 ans que la
balance commerciale et notre industrie
plonge
ça devrait faire réfléchir
amener des remises en cause
et bien non il y en a jamais assez
et raré ou manounes persévérer
persévérer diabolique
car excusez du peu c'est 150 milliards
annuels
sensibles âge on cible même pas les plus
touchés vers le commerce extérieur ou
l'industrie sans contrepartie on emploie
ou en investissement
et donc nous estimons qu'il faut stopper
ce gâchis d'argent
public et réorienter ses crédits vers un
soutien ciblé durable dans le cas de
plan de filière et d'une véritable
politique industrielle
cette politique doit aussi les
partenaires sociaux les collectivités
bien sur les régions mais les autres
l'Éducation Nationale Universitaire les
centres de recherche et de formation
c'est une mobilisation générale du pays
qui s'impose
et une politique nouvelle industrielle
qui doit s'appuyer
1 sur la création de la véritable
ministère de l'Industrie
indépendant de Bercy avec une
administration propre complètement
orientée vers cet objectif
et qui serait l'acteur de cette
mobilisation et travaillerait que le
Commissariat général au Plan
deuxièmement nous croyons qu'il faut des
plantes filières bien sûr dans les
domaines stratégiques mais pas seulement
car la réindustrialisation doit se faire
dans la plupart des secteurs de notre
pays il faut donc évidemment par filière
des plans qui graduent le soutien
l'effort les aides mais ne négligeons
aucun secteur car c'est bien la
diversité du tissu industriel qui permet
sa réindustrialisation petite et grande
entreprise si chers collègues je
terminerai non non merci je terminerai
simplement en disant chers
il faut encore que je répète comment ça
se passe merci
le ministre
si beaucoup mesdames la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je partage avec vous un constat oui
pendant plus de 20 ans depuis le début
des années 90 jusque au début des années
2010 notre pays a fait beaucoup
d'efforts et avec grand succès pour se
désindustrialiser nous avons peut-être
cru tout gouvernement confondu
d'ailleurs de gauche comme de droite au
mirage de la Chine en disant ça va
coûter moins cher on sera plus
compétitif finalement en allant produits
ailleurs et on a été pris par ce
merveilleux effet ciseau qui fait que
quand on ne produit plus chez nous non
seulement on n'exporte plus nos produits
mais on est en plus obligé d'importer ce
qu'il nous faut dans notre propre pays
et nous avons creusé de manière
constante notre déficit de la balance
des biens
aujourd'hui ce mouvement de
désindustrialisation il est inversé
c'est à dire que depuis si Madame depuis
trois ans nous créons plus d'emplois
industriels que nous en détruisons nous
construisons plus d'usines que nous
enfermons d'un point de vue industriel
et nous avons avec les gouvernements du
président de la République lancée le
plan France 2030 qui est un magnifique
outil pour réindustrialiser notre pays
et j'en veux pour preuve les usines qui
aujourd'hui sortent de terre dans les
semi-conducteurs accroll près de
Grenoble dans la fabrication de
paracétamol de savent sur les principes
actifs avec séquence dans l'Isère ou
encore en matière de lithium sur les
matières stratégiques que ce soit dans
l'Allier ou dans le Bas-Rhin donc oui la
réindustrialisation est en marche oui
elle prendra du temps parce que on ne
inverse pas 20 ans de DS
Industrialisation en deux ans donc ça
prendra une décennie mais elle est mise
en œuvre par les gouvernements du
président de la République
merci Madame Lindeman
il nous faudrait du temps pour démonter
le discours mirobolant sur l'arrière
industrialisation je ne nie pas que
grâce à l'intervention de l'État on a
réouvert certaines usines simplement
c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt parce
qu'à 17h entier qui sont en train de
distribuer et franchement la reconquête
du médicament par le paracétamol seul ne
suffira pas nos collègues l'ont très
bien exprimé je voudrais surtout dire
que tout le monde n'était pas Béa devant
la désindustrialisation les syndicats en
particulier mais c'est la conséquence de
cette vision de la mondialisation
heureuse du libre-échange généralisé
c'était pas grave d'aller prendre un
Chine parce que ça coûtait moins cher
ben justement aujourd'hui le temps est
venu de rompre avec les politiques
européennes qui font du libre-échange
généralisé la règle et pas seulement
dans les échanges internationaux car
c'est en France le gros de son déficit
il vient du commerce intra-européen
parce qu'au sein de l'Union européenne
merci chers respectez vos camarades s'il
vous plaît vos collègues voilà merci la
parole est à Madame Daphné rakmadou pour
le groupe Union centriste pour 4 minutes
de chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
face au retour en force d'un
protectionnisme classique couplé à
réarmement commercial inédit il est plus
que jamais nécessaire de bâtir une
stratégie commerciale résolument
ambitieuse afin de garantir la
compétitivité à l'international de nos
entreprises le travail prospectif mené
par la délégation sénatoriale aux
entreprises et ses rapporteurs et
salutaire et permet d'inscrire ce sujet
à l'agenda du débat du débat public je
souhaite donc féliciter Florence platrix
compta Vincent Segoin et Jean ingrey
pour la qualité de leurs travaux et de
leur recommandation un travail d'autant
plus important qu'en matière commerciale
la sonnette d'alarme devait être tirée
depuis longtemps
ainsi le déficit de la balance
commerciale française c'est fortement
aggravé en 2022 passant de 82 après 264
milliards d'euros en plus en plus d'un
phénomène structurel connu de longue
date le renchérissement de la facture
énergétique associée à la forte
dépréciation de l'euro face au dollar a
fait plonger notre balance commerciale
chers collègues notre dépendance aux
importations et nous le savons
problématique et remet en cause notre
souveraineté si l'on met de côté la
question préoccupante de l'énergie notre
déficit structurel c'est creusé dans des
proportions inquiétantes fleuron
français aéronautique voit sa balance
excédentaire passer 31 milliards d'euros
à 20 milliards entre 2019 et 2022 soit
une chute de 35% sur trois ans à ces
chiffres symptomatiques d'une politique
commerciale touchée par un mal profond
s'ajoute une concurrence internationale
acharnée
avec la fin des restrictions sanitaires
Pékin renoue avec sa politique
commerciale offensive en misant sur sa
main d'oeuvre peu qualifiée et ses
géants industriels ultra compétitifs
Washington a récemment adopté Nintendo
370 milliards d'euros visant à soutenir
les entreprises américaines produisant
éoliennes panneaux solaires et véhicules
électriques avec nos partenaires
européens nous devons agir rapidement
pour permettre à nos entreprises de
continuer à trouver des débouchés sur
les marchés internationaux tout en
restant compétitive je salue à ce titre
l'action du gouvernement ayant conduit
au niveau européen à la mise en oeuvre
d'un plan industriel communautaire pour
impact vert présenté par la commission
mercredi dernier la création d'un Fonds
européen souveraineté à destination de
nos acteurs économiques est ainsi un
signal fort envoyé par la Commission
en complément l'échelle nationale nous
devons mieux accompagner nos TPE PME et
ETI à l'international la mise en oeuvre
de la team France Export dans la lignée
de la stratégie de Roubaix en février
2018 est à titre d'exemple un véritable
succès c'est désormais un outil clé
ayant accompagné plus de 10500 PME et
ETI françaises en 2021 si nous ne
pouvons que nous féliciter de ces
réformes et de ses avancées il reste
tant à faire mes chers collègues
trois recommandations du rapport me
semble devoir être soutenu à ce titre
nous devons tout d'abord continuer à
investir dans la formation dans le
secondaire et le supérieur afin de doter
nos entreprises de professionnels agiles
et à l'aise à l'international pouvant
faciliter l'insertion des entreprises
sur les marchés nous devons ensuite
mieux identifier les risques de
vulnérabilité d'approvisionnement en
utilisant les données douanières
européennes c'est une condition
impérative pour garantir notre
souveraineté commerciale enfin il est
urgent de définir une vision stratégique
à horizon 2040 voire 2035 en matière de
commerce extérieur avant de fin de
s'attaquer aux racines structurelles de
notre déficit cette vision doit
s'appuyer sur deux piliers principaux
d'une part une meilleure synergie entre
les nombreux et différentes dispositifs
existants
pour une politique plus efficiente et
d'autre part l'inscription dans une loi
de programmation des objectifs précis de
réduction du déficit afin de bâtir une
trajectoire lisible et cohérente pour
l'ensemble des acteurs mes chers
collègues nous le savons le chantier est
immense et nous appartient désormais
avec un engagement total merci
j'aurais éventuellement la possibilité
de reprendre après monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
Madame et messieurs les sénateurs
je partage évidemment avec vous un
certain nombre de constats en dehors de
la situation exceptionnelle sur la
facture énergétique nous avons dans
notre balance des biens un déficit
structurel ce déficit structurel on
vient de le voir tout à l'heure répond
pour une grande part à la question de la
désindustrialisation et pour une autre
part en réalité à la faiblesse de nos
PME à l'exportation et ça c'est un sujet
sur lequel nous travaillons avec la team
France Export vous parlez de la
formation je parlerai aussi de la
culture de nos chefs d'entreprise à
l'international c'est à dire que nous
avons en France cette particularité
peut-être parce que notre pays est
agréable et que l'on s'y sent bien de ne
pas être tourné instinctivement vers
l'international et je pense qu'il y a là
une véritable faible véritable travail à
faire je me permettrai juste le temps
mettant compter une remarque sur
l'aéronautique puisque vous avez pointé
justement le fait que il manquait à peu
près il y a aujourd'hui un peu moins de
10 milliards d'euros par rapport au
chiffre que l'on avait avant covid sur
la filière aéronautique nous sommes la
véritablement dans un phénomène
conjoncturel qui est celui évidemment de
la baisse de régime du secteur durant le
covid et aujourd'hui surtout sur l'année
2022 j'avais le président d'Airbus au
téléphone encore avant-hier soir sur les
semi-conducteurs il y a de très nombreux
avions qui n'ont pas pu être livrés
parce que les semis conducteurs
n'étaient pas là mais nous sommes très
confiants sur la filière on va rattraper
ce retard l'année 2023 on a plus de 7200
avions dans les carnets de commandes
voilà donc on peut être tout à fait
confiant sur le fait que le secteur
économique récupère le niveau d'avant
crise très prochainement merci
merci Madame rakmadou alors la parole
est donc à Madame Ghislaine Pentel pour
le groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
et social européen pour 5 minutes chers
collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
Délégation aux entreprises madame
monsieur des rapporteurs mes chers
collègues
je vous parle d'un temps que les moins
de 20 ans ne peuvent pas connaître la
chanson d'Aznavour s'appliquerait bien à
l'histoire de notre balance commerciale
ces dernières décennies
s'il est difficile de l'état de la
sécurité sociale ont bientôt une
demi-siècle en matière commerciale la
France était restée exportatrice nette
de bien jusqu'au début des années 2000 à
l'époque du gouvernement Jospin et de la
gauche pluriel notre pays était encore
une grande puissance commerciale en
Europe et dans le monde depuis notre
base commerciale n'a cessé de se
dégrader un cap supplémentaire a été
franchi depuis la crise sanitaire avec
un déficit commercial qui a dépassé 80
milliards d'euros en 2021 et qui aurait
exposé à plus de 150 milliards en 2022
en particulier il est vrai à cause de la
crise énergétique entraînée par la
guerre en Ukraine
comment expliquer ce phénomène désormais
structurel il faut mettre au crédit de
la délégation sénatoriale aux
entreprises de s'être penchées sur cette
question épineuse mais si important
c'est important et même salutaire
au sein d'une Union européenne qui
équilibre à peu près ces comptes
extérieurs la France apparaît à la
remorque de l'Allemagne et même de
l'Italie qui ont su conserver une
balance commerciale positive
il y aurait des choses à dire sur le
bien fondé d'un commerce allemand aussi
fortement excédentaire revers d'une
consommation intérieure à tonne et des
exportations parfois au détriment de ses
partenaires européens
ces questions sont débattues depuis des
années avec les crises qui ont secoué la
zone euro
toutefois cela nous empêche pas de
regarder certaines réalités en face et
de trouver des solutions aux faiblesses
structurelles de l'économie française le
brexit a probablement renforcé ses
difficultés car c'est avec le royaume
unique que nous avions notre plus gros
excédent commercial même si le coût
principal du brexit est bien sûr pour le
Royaume-Uni lui-même
le déficit commercial de la France n'est
pas du qu'elle a facture énergétique
cette dernière représente une part
certes importante mais les pertes de
part de marché à l'exportation se sont
accumulés dans de nombreux secteurs sur
le long terme
cet affaiblissement cet affaiblissement
touche aujourd'hui non seulement
l'industrie mais aussi de secteur
agroalimentaire en outre le rapport ami
à lumière les risques qui pèsent sur les
services avec le phénomène de
télémigration
c'est un phénomène qu'on a commencé à
envisager avec la généralisation du
télétravail mais mesure-t-on encore bien
son ampleur
le secteur des services est pourtant un
domaine où la France reste exportatrice
si l'on prend la balance courante et
plus seulement la balance de commerce de
biens le déficit en 2021 est ramené à
une vingtaine de milliards d'euros
seulement c'est une nuance intéressante
face au discours souvent à l'armiste
malgré tout notre position extérieure
nette n'a cessé de se dégrader sur une
longue période
les faiblesses de nos PME à l'export ne
sont pas nouvelles la France continue de
manquer de grosses PME exportatrices à
l'instar de leurs homologues de
homologues allemandes ou italienne
certains ont voulu incriminer la monnaie
unique et l'absence de zone monétaire
optimale mais les difficultés similaires
rencontrées par le Royaume-Uni qui n'a
jamais été dans la zone euro montre que
cette question est plus complexe
face à tous ces défis que faire
j'identifierai trois axes d'abord la
remontée en garde de notre production
nous devons impérativement améliorer la
qualité moyenne de nos produits dans de
nombreux secteurs hormis quelques
domaines d'excellence d'économie
française souffre de se situer trop dans
la moyenne gamme cette remontée
nécessite d'importance investissements
tant public que privé ensuite le cadre
réglementaire et fiscal un amendement
proposé par mon groupe dans la dernière
loi de finance visite à préserver la
souveraineté économique dans le secteur
des services numériques face au risque
de prise de contrôle hostile le cadre
concerne aussi les modalités de
transposition des directives européennes
dans ce domaine le Sénat pourrait-il
pourrait lui-même lutter contre sa
propre tendance à la surtransposition
enfin et surtout la réindustrialisation
doit aujourd'hui être levier de la
transition écologique dans ce domaine
les pouvoirs publics états et
collectivités ont un collectivité
territoriale un rôle crucial à jouer
voici les quelques remarques que je
souhaitais faire au nom du groupe RDSE
et qui sont loin d'épuiser ce vaste
sujet merci merci chers collègues
monsieur le ministre
dès que notre collègue a rejoint une
place merci
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
vous me permettrez de ne pas être
d'accord sur un certain nombre de points
de votre propos d'abord
nous avons une situation qui est
particulièrement conjoncturel sur
l'énergie et qui est vrai d'ailleurs
pour tous nos partenaires européens y
compris l'Allemagne qui avait de très
forts excédents et qui va voir ces
excédents fondent de plus de 100
milliards d'euros et l'Italie qui était
également habitué aux excédents et qui
cette fois-ci va se retrouver comme nous
dans un déficit commercial assez
important donc on voit bien à quel point
cette question de l'énergie elle est
conjoncturelle et elle emporte
l'ensemble des pays européens deuxième
point de désaccord sur l'agroalimentaire
l'agroalimentaire en France est
excédentaire nous avons plus de 10
milliards d'euros d'excédent sur
l'agroalimentaire et ces deux milliards
de plus sur l'année 2022 c'est à dire
que nous avons des filières sur les
céréales et sur l'élevage tout
particulièrement qui sont très
dynamiques c'est pas simplement les vins
et spiritueux donc ce sont des bonnes
nouvelles pour le commerce extérieur
français et un point évidemment sur
lequel nous serons d'accord en revanche
c'est la question des PME PMI nous avons
effectivement un tissu de PME PMI
française plus faible que ce que nous
avons en Allemagne et en Italie et
surtout nos PME sont très faiblement
portés vers l'exportation et c'est là le
gros défi que nous avons devant nous
autant la réindustrialisation ça prendra
du temps je l'ai dit tout à l'heure il
faudra une décennie pour
réindustrialiser notre pays et en voir
véritablement les effets autant les PME
nous pouvons les pousser à l'exportation
et c'est notamment le défi de la team
France Export merci
merci d'accord donc la parole est à
madame Martin de Sidrac pour le groupe
les républicains pour 7 minutes chers
collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues le long
des clins de notre balance commerciale
porte en lui nombre des mots qui
affectent l'économie française depuis
plusieurs décennies des
industrialisations fiscalité écrasante
sur la production et la transmission
d'entreprise une structuration française
qui peine à installer d'intermédiaires
entre petites et moyennes entreprises et
entreprises du CAC 40 lourdeur et
complexité administrative bref nous
traînons ces faire au pied depuis bien
trop longtemps et je me réjouis que nos
collègues de la délégation aux
entreprises qui soient penchées je salue
le travail des rapporteurs qui a pu
aboutir à des propositions concrètes qui
je l'espère seront entendues un couragés
car le constat est sévère mais hélas
réaliste la France n'exporte pas assez
les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes et sont
d'ailleurs particulièrement mauvais en
ce qui concerne ces dernières années le
déficit commercial était de 84 milliards
en 20 21 pour atteindre le chiffre
record de 160 milliards d'euros en 2022
dans la période precovide il était
solidement ancré autour de 60 milliards
de déficits avec un plongeon
significatif de 15 milliards de déficits
supplémentaires entre 2016 et 2017 à la
racine de ce mal français la faible part
de l'industrie dans le produit intérieur
brut qui n'a cessé de plonger
aujourd'hui ça part dans le PIB n'est
que de très ennemis pour cent quand la
moyenne européenne est autour de 15%.
pour rappel ces 24,2 en Allemagne 196 en
Italie ou 15 8 en Espagne vous trouverez
tous ces chiffres dans le très bon
rapport de mes collègues Florence
blatrix compta Jean ingray et Vincent
Segoin revenons d'ailleurs quelques
années en arrière lorsque sous
l'impulsion de certaines théories
économiques nous pensions que ce monde
qui vient serait celui des services et
non plus de l'industrie avec cette idée
folle des mêmes auteurs les pays
développés délocaliseraient leurs
production à l'étranger pour ne garder
que que les services malheureusement
l'hémorragie qui s'en est suivies chacun
la connaît notre industrie a payé un
lourd tribu à ses idées mortifères
perdant 10 points dans la part du pipe
qu'elle est occupé pour mémoire chers
collègues le déficit commercial de la
France était jusqu'à lors inférieur à
l'Allemagne un exemple symptomatique
comment expliquer aujourd'hui que les
constructeurs automobiles français parmi
les plus importants au monde pèsent si
peu dans les exportations nationales
c'est la particulièrement frappant notre
industrie automobile c'est délocaliser
depuis 20 ans attirés par le coup
attractif de la main d'oeuvre étrangère
dans le même temps l'industrie
automobile allemande s'est adossé sur
les anciens pays d'Europe centrale et
orientale comme arrière boutique tout en
conservant un assemblage final en
Allemagne made in Germany résultat notre
balance commerciale automobile n'a plus
été excédentaire depuis 2004 et comble
de l'ironie certains constructeurs
français sont aujourd'hui devenus un
porteur sur le marché national
nous devons être interpellés par ces
exemples qui pourraient être multipliés
s'appliqués à bien des domaines ces
dernières décennies en partant de ce
triste constat un autre émerge les
productions étrangères affluent
maintenant en quantité sur le territoire
national nous sommes devenus un pays
d'importation des denrées et des
produits du bout du monde dans des
emballages du bout du monde notre
déficit commercial ne l’évalue pas mais
nous importons en réalité les déchets de
demain les mêmes qui n'ont créé ni
emploi ni richesse ni savoir-faire dans
notre pays monsieur le ministre je
plaide pour que nos politiques publiques
prennent conscience de ce fait
d'importance et soutient de la création
d'une puissante filaire industrielle
française de traitement des déchets
compétitifs et innovantes dans un
contexte de rareté de diminution des
ressources mondiales repensant notre
rapport aux déchets
s'assurer aujourd'hui de leur
valorisation c'est permettre demain de
garder un levier important sur les
ressources
développer une puissante filière
française du recyclage et du réemploi
sera incontestablement également un
moyen de création d'emplois et de
développement économique dans nos
territoires et nous aidera à changer
notre rapport aux échanges commerciaux
notre pays a de nombreux atouts à faire
valoir qui nous permettraient de
retrouver de la compétitivité et de
garantir notre souveraineté nos
politiques publiques doivent en tenir
compte valoriser et accompagner ses
atouts pour que la France redevienne une
grande puissance commerciale
sortons de la mondialisation heureuse
qui nous a fait si mal par le passé
redécouvrons un état stratège qui
garantit notre souveraineté et notre
autonomie stratégique je ne serai pas
plus long que chers collègues merci
beaucoup chers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
je partage votre votre constat notamment
sur la désindustrialisation je viens de
le dire je partage également votre
préoccupation sur la question de la
valorisation des déchets et du
traitement déchets nous avons besoin
d'une politique industrielle dans ce
domaine là et ça fait partie des
orientations du plan France 2030
notamment ce qui concerne les matériaux
c'est d'ailleurs on va dire une étape
indispensable pour la mise en place de
cette économie circulaire que nous
appelons évidemment de notre vœu pour la
défense de l'environnement et la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
donc vous voyez qu'on a des analyses
extrêmement proches juste sur
l'automobile
nous avons des chiffres qui aujourd'hui
sont plutôt encourageants puisque nous
avons dans cette année très particulière
encore une fois où on a beaucoup manqué
de semi-conducteur pour soutenir
justement la production automobile
dépit de ça nous avons des chiffres dans
le secteur automobile qui rejoignent la
situation d'avant covid donc nous avons
rattrapé si vous voulez le retard que
nous avions l'année précédente et c'est
aussi une bonne nouvelle pour ce secteur
merci
monsieur le ministre bien évidemment je
suis aussi d'accord sur ce que vous
venez de dire puisque vous étiez
d'accord avec mes propres propos donc
évidemment on est d'accord simplement je
voudrais vraiment insister sur un aspect
qui est important me semble-t-il c'est
que nous nous importons beaucoup nous
n'exportons pas assez donc soutenons
aussi des talents et des savoir-faire
typiquement français j'ai presque envie
de dire de fait même que nous sommes
pays d'importateur nous pouvons aussi
exporter ce savoir-faire dans beaucoup
de pays y compris en Europe car nous
avons de vrais talents en la matière et
de très belles entreprises pas que de
très grosses parfois les PME et les TPE
sont très bonnes en ces matières là
voilà
merci la parole est à Madame Vanina
paoliga Jean pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 5 minutes
monsieur le ministre madame et Messieurs
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues le
creusement progressif de notre déficit
commercial dure depuis tant d'années que
certains si sont presque habitués allant
jusqu'à le qualifier de structurel
chaque année plus le déficit tricolore
s'enlise plus ils deviennent urgent de
redresser la barre chaque année les
mauvais choix de ces 30 dernières années
en matière de politique industrielle se
rappelle à nous
pourtant les alertes se sont multipliées
à l'instar du rapport déposé en 2018 par
mon collègue Jean-Pierre de colle sur la
pénurie de médicaments il demeure
malheureusement toujours d'actualité
j'ai un petit problème
de papier
la crise covid à braquer un projecteur
sans concession sur notre décrochage
industriel et la perte de compétitivité
de nos entreprises elle a posé une
lumière crue sur le vieillissement de
notre appareil productif sur les
délocalisations de nos emplois sur la
fuite ininterrompue de nombreux de nos
talents et sur l'inadéquation de notre
positionnement milieu de gamme cela a
déjà été dit alors que nous sommes
confrontés de plein fouet aux pénuries
au renchérissement du coût de l'énergie
à notre dépendance aux importations les
manquements de notre politique
commerciale nous obligent s'accorder sur
un même constat est un premier pas
réaliser un état des lieux des 900
postes et produits affichant un déficit
supérieur à 50 millions d'euros comme
l'a fait le Haut Commissariat aux plans
et déjà une bonne chose désormais nous
devons surtout agir et vite
l'étude de notre balance commerciale
pose aussi la question de notre
politique dédiée à la recherche oubliez
Lisbonne et mourir c'est un peu ce que
nous avons fait là ce monsieur le
ministre
je vous le rappelle mes chers collègues
l'Europe devait être l'économie la plus
compétitive du monde en 2010 et nous
devions consacrer 3 % de notre pays B à
la R&D la France est malheureusement
encore loin du compte pourtant les
chiffres montrent bien que des
entreprises actives en R&D exportent
plus nos grandes entreprises impliquées
aux R&D réalisent 31% de leur chiffre
d'affaires à l'export contre 23% pour le
reste des grandes entreprises c'est
encore plus flagrant pardon pour les PME
celle qui sont actives en R&D réalisent
29% de leur chiffre d'affaires à
l'export contre seulement 10% pour
l'ensemble des PME
bon espoir monsieur le ministre dans le
plan France 2030 même si des lourdeurs
bureaucratiques freinent encore son
déploiement il met l'accent sur la
formation et la recherche qu'on a aussi
pris en compte dans la LPR dans des
domaines stratégiques parmi eux le
spatial des carbonations de l'industrie
et la santé sont des secteurs dans
laquelle la France doit rapidement se
positionner
développer une stratégie française en
faveur de la recherche est un enjeu de
souveraineté majeur et nous avons encore
de bonnes raisons d'espérer dans
certains domaines la France est même
très bien positionnée le luxe ou
l'agroalimentaire bien sûr ont été
évoqués mais d'autres secteurs encore
représentent fièrement notre pays à
l'international
parmi eux je voudrais saluer le secteur
du jouet et du jeu de société tout un
écosystème de talentueux professionnel
dont on parle peu qui s'emploie à
soutenir la dynamique de cette industrie
qui par la conquête des marchés
internationaux dans l'Aube c'est le cas
par exemple de l'entreprise fériocrite à
Mussy-sur-Seine le festival
international International des Jeux se
tiendra à Cannes à la fin du mois sa
présidente édition avait réuni plus de
80 000 passionnés venant du monde entier
une réussite du made in France qui
souligne l'urgence du rapatriement de
certaines productions comme les éléments
magnétiques ou encore les bus
électroniques ces exemples donnent de
l'espoir mais ne peuvent malheureusement
faire oublier de la situation le statut
connaît plus permis dans le rapport
d'information transformer l'essai
d'innovation un impératif pour
réindustrialiser la France dont j'étais
le rapporteur nous dénoncions le
saupoudrage d'aide publique mais aussi
les délais d'autorisation de mise sur le
marché etc ces délais sont incompatibles
avec le développement rapide des
secteurs technologiques innovants à
titre d'exemple sur les biocontrôles qui
vous le savez sont des substituts aux
pesticides ou la France est innovante il
faut 7 à 18 mois aux USA et 7000 dollars
avec la procédure Fastrac pour
homologuer un produit il faut 18
voir plutôt 36 mois auprès de l'ESTA à
des coûts bien supérieurs et encore en
passant par la Belgique car nos 36 en
France est submergé et saturé c'est un
vrai problème de commerce extérieur
monsieur le ministre indirect mais c'est
un vrai problème ça coûte à nos
entreprises elle subit des décalages
dans leur plan d'affaires et elle
perdent leur avance compétitive j'espère
que l'IRA européen viendra apporter les
améliorations nécessaires pour stopper
l'hémorragie je vous remercie merci
chers collègues
monsieur le ministre
vous pouvez vous installer où vous
voulez même pas oligargent bien sûr
pas de souci
la présidente mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je suis d'accord avec vous sur de
nombreux points notamment sur 1 il faut
agir et vite
et c'est ce que nous faisons notamment à
travers le plan France 2030 en matière
d'innovation parce que vous avez
parfaitement raison
il faut relocaliser un certain nombre de
secteurs qui sont des secteurs
stratégiques on a parlé tout à l'heure
des semi-conducteurs on a parlé de la
pharmacie avec un certain nombre de
médicaments essentiels on peut parler
également de composants nécessaires à la
transition énergétique les batteries et
donc les matières premières dont on a
besoin pour confectionner ces batteries
mais on ne va pas tout relocaliser
pourquoi parce que et ça a été dit très
justement tout à l'heure on ne va pas se
lancer aujourd'hui dans une nouvelle
compétition de compétitivité coût on
trouvera toujours des pays dans le monde
si ce n'est pas l'Asie demain ce sera
l'Afrique où on arrivera à produire des
produits à faible valeur ajoutée à des
coûts bien moins importants que ce que
nous ferons en France et donc il est
important de d'accès aujourd'hui la
réindustrialisation en dehors de ce que
je viens de dire sur les matières
stratégiques sur les questions
d'innovation c'est à dire les produits
qui porteront la croissance des
prochaines décennies et c'est ce que
nous faisons dans France 2030 à travers
les énergies du futur à travers les
biotechnologies à travers les mobilités
du futur c'est ça le combat et vous
pouvez compter évidemment sur le
gouvernement pour agir et vite dans ces
domaines
c'est
doux à mes oreilles monsieur le ministre
mais j'avais quand même pointé le fait
que nos règlementations nos délais
d'homologation c'est vraiment un caillou
dans la chaussure des innovateurs dans
notre pays ils partent en ce moment au
Canada aux États-Unis on leur construit
des usines qu'on qui sont payés à 80 %,
on leur garantit un prix de
l'électricité sur 10 ans et on leur
permet d'homologuer leurs produits ils
vont revenir via les procédures au CDE
en Europe et en France est-ce qu'ils
vont revenir rapatrier la production
chez nous je le souhaite mais c'est pas
sûr
merci la parole est à Monsieur Daniel
salmon pour le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame le présidente monsieur le
ministre madame monsieur les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues notre pays affiche
un déficit record qui atteint désormais
150 milliards fin 2022 comme le souligne
justement ce rapport les raisons des
contreperformances sont déjà été
évoquées à des contre-performances à
répétition du commerce extérieur elles
sont connues il est déficitaire
maintenant depuis près de 20 ans et
l'envoler de la facture énergétique le
ralentissement du commerce mondial et la
dépréciation de l'euro face au dollar
ont accentué son plongeon mais c'est
bien évidemment les achats d'énergie
d'hydrocarbures bien sûr et les
importations d'électricité qui pèsent le
plus dans le creusement de ces derniers
mois permettez-moi donc d'accès mon
discours mon propos sur cet angle
énergétique qui est l'une des raisons
majeures de notre vulnérabilité et de
notre déficit commercial
rappelons que la France qu'en France
près des deux tiers de notre
consommation énergétique dépendent
encore des énergies fossiles dont une
partie est toujours importée de Russie
une situation de dépendance mortifère
pour le climat pour la paix critique
pour nos comptes publics et qui n'est
pas non plus le pouvoir de vivre de nos
concitoyens
l'objectif de la Commission européenne à
travers le plan ripower qui vise à se
passer du pétrole gaz et charbon russe
d'ici à 2027 et bien sûr nécessaire mais
le réveil est bien tardif
les importations d'électricité pèsent
également dans le creusement de ces
derniers mois nous l'avons dit notamment
du fait de l'indisponibilité de nombreux
réacteurs nucléaires
demfait qui me permettent de rappeler
l'impériose nécessité du déploiement des
énergies renouvelables pour notre
souveraineté énergétique en premier lieu
et pour contribuer des facto à la bonne
santé de notre balance commerciale alors
qu'elle représente la source
d'électricité barcarbone et compétitive
pouvant être déployés massivement sur le
territoire à l'horizon 2030 nous ne
pouvons que déplorer notre faiblesse en
la matière et ceci à plusieurs niveaux
importations d'électricité donc mais
importation également des moyens de
production et bien sûr faiblesse de nos
exportations sur l'éolien les Danois les
Allemands sont à l'avant-garde du marché
mondial aucun constructeur français dans
les 10 premiers sur le photovoltaïque
c'est la Chine qui monopolise
aujourd'hui toutes les étapes de la
chaîne de production en pratiquant du
dumping social et environnemental sans
que la Commission européenne y trouve à
redire
en ayant investi 50 milliards de dollars
dans le développement du secteur dès
2011 10 fois plus que l'Europe sa part
de marché mondial dépasse les 80%. alors
que l'Union européenne apporte 84% de
ses équipements la Chine domine à
présent les chaînes d'approvisionnement
dans leur ensemble toutes sur toutes ces
technologies essentielles à la
transition en plus du solaire nous
pouvons également citer les véhicules
électriques et le stockage d'électricité
dans le domaine de l'hydroélectricité la
France ne tient pas non plus son rang au
niveau de l'exportation de sa
technologie
alors que sur ces questions majeures la
France et l'Europe accumulent un retard
préoccupant le plan anti-inflation
adopté en 2022 aux États-Unis visant à
combattre le changement climatique
favorise la relocalisation industrielle
dans des secteurs stratégiques de la
transition l'inflation réduction actes
met en place un arsenal de mesure
incitatives notamment via des crédits
d'impôt à l'investissement et à la
production d'équipements de la
transition énergétique pour une
enveloppe de 369 milliards d'euros avec
un objectif de relocaliser une capacité
intégrée de 50 GW par an d'ici 2030 50
gigawatts ce n'est pas rien face à ces
subventions massives pour relocaliser la
production des moyens de production de
NR de la part des autres grandes
puissances quelle initiative monsieur le
ministre la France va-t-elle engager
pour une réelle relocalisation de la
chaîne de valeur comment notre pays se
donne-t-il les moyens de redevenir
constructeur et exportateurs dans ses
filières qui hélas n'ont jamais été
soutenu
si la France veut sécuriser son
découplage énergétique avec la Russie et
les autres pays et garder la distance
dans la transition vis-à-vis de la Chine
et des États-Unis elle doit reconstruire
une base industrielle sur son territoire
en la tournant résolument vers la
transition écologique cela passe par la
fabrication des équipements au plus près
mais aussi par la mise en place d'une
taxe carbone aux frontières de l'Europe
en privilégiant l'industrie plutôt que
la libre concurrence oui le combat face
aux changements climatique va favoriser
plus que jamais la recoller
relocalisation de la production dans ces
filières clés et l'un des industriels
actives dans la transition ont
aujourd'hui besoin de visibilité pour
démarrer des investissements très
coûteux en capital vous annoncez un
projet de loi cette année pour une
industrie verte qui devrait être
occasion de répondre à ces défis majeurs
mais sans amorcer un réel changement de
paradigme dans des politiques publiques
sans introduire la moindre
conditionnalité à l'attribution des
publics sans un être investissement
massif dans les EnR le feu restera un
vœu pieux je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs sur
le sénateur
un point juste d'informations sur le
pétrole brut russe nous sommes arrivés à
0 %. donc il n'y a plus d'importation de
pétrole brut russe en France à l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle de la même
manière qu'il n'y a plus de soutien
public que ce soit à l'export ou
ailleurs sur les énergies fossiles
nous partageons évidemment un constat
c'est que il n'y aura pas de réindustrie
d'isation possible si il n'y a pas une
énergie abondante et pas chère et pour
avoir une énergie abondante et pas chère
nous devons être à la fois dans les
énergies renouvelables mais nous devons
être aussi dans les énergies back
carbone parce que c'est ce qui permettra
de répondre à la demande qui sera
probablement croissante ces prochaines
années en termes d'énergie
et donc le plan France 2030 qui soutient
la redistradiation dont nous parlions à
l'instant a mis en place les soutiens
nécessaires pour que l'on puisse à la
fois dans l'éolien offshore mais aussi
dans les nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires
notamment les petits réacteurs
modulaires avoir un temps d'avance en
matière technologique par rapport à nos
principaux compétiteurs ça m'offre
l'occasion très rapidement puisque le
temps met compté d'aborder l'infection
réduction actes il est évident que ce
que nous lançons au niveau européen ne
peut marcher que si nous avons une
concurrence qui est une concurrence
équitable et loyale notamment vis-à-vis
de nos alliés américains et donc nous
sommes en discussion avec les États-Unis
d'Amérique et en parallèle à ces
discussions nous avons également un plan
européen qui est en train de se monter
qui sera au menu du Conseil européen qui
se réunira en fin de semaine à Bruxelles
et je suis particulièrement confiance
sur le fait que nous arriverons à
trouver ensemble les réponses pour
assurer la compétitivité de nos
entreprises dans ces secteurs là en
Europe et particulièrement en France
Merci monsieur salmon merci madame le
Président Monsieur le Ministre nous
avons un désaccord de fond je pense que
l'investissement dans le nucléaire
clairement va nous donner plutôt un
temps de retard encore une nouvelle fois
sur les énergies renouvelables je vais
vous donner aussi un exemple sur les
problèmes sur le commerce extérieur je
suis président du groupe d'amitié France
Népal je me suis rendu au Népal en
septembre dernier il y a un projet
d'hydroélectricité vous savez que le
Népal a un potentiel d'hydroélectricité
gigantesque 50 gigawatts potentiellement
et ils attendent des partenaires la
France avait EDF est engagée dans un
projet ça fait des années et ça patine
ça n'avance pas un autre exemple
Katmandou attend d'avoir un téléphérique
il y a une société iseroise Poma qui est
engagée sur ce projet ça fait là
également des années et on n'avance pas
donc je pense qu'on a vraiment une
nécessité d'être plus offensif et
d'arriver à peser et arriver à débloquer
ses problèmes qui a passé ses projets
qui sont vraiment excellents pour le
commerce extérieur français
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Baptiste
Lemoine pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
merci beaucoup madame la présidence
madame messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le ministre bon c'est pas la
saint Olivier aujourd'hui puisque c'est
le 12 juillet je vous la prends mais
c'est votre journée je crois entre ce
débat ce soir les chiffres rendus
publics par la douane ce matin avec
effectivement ce nouveau record qui a
été atteint en termes de déficit
commercial avec moins 163 milliards
d'euros et hélas ça devient un peu un
marronnier en réalité et on a coutume
effectivement chaque mois de février de
verser des larmes de crocodile sur les
chiffres du commerce extérieur depuis 20
ans parce que la tendance elle est là
parce qu'elle est lourde mais l'examen
attentif des chiffres je crois doit
également inciter néanmoins à ne pas
perdre espoir parce que le chiffre en
pied de colonne il cache en réalité
beaucoup de nuances beaucoup de
surprises et je crois qu'il faut avoir
tous ces éléments en tête pour
effectivement bâtir une approche
stratégique comme l'appel de nos vœux
les rapporteurs et donc quelques
éléments peut-être que je voulais mettre
à jour à travers les chiffres rendus
publics ce matin bon première chose ça a
été dit je paye revenir trop longtemps
la part importante de l'énergie dans le
déficit ça a été dit 80% durant
chérissement enfin 80% de
l'accroissement du déficit lié au
renchrissement de la facture énergétique
et donc en mettant les bouchées doubles
sur cette transition énergétique on voit
qu'on apporte une réponse structurelle à
une partie d'autres déficit et imaginez
le monde de demain avec une France
autonome en énergie d'ailleurs on le
voit la Banque de France qui est aussi
publié ce matin un certain nombre de
données le dit le déficit des biens hors
énergie est stable à -24 milliards
d'euros donc je crois qu'il faut
également pointer cet élément alors dans
ce contexte il est très important de pas
se laisser doubler effectivement par
nos partenaires d'outre atlantiques d'où
l'importance effectivement du Green Deal
industriel plane pour assouplir les
règles sur les aides d'État jusqu'en
2025 capitale deuxième point que je
relève c'est l'augmentation du nombre
d'entreprise exportatrice et également
l'augmentation des exportations et
lorsqu'on 2018 nous avions lancé la
stratégie team français export le pari
c'était d'augmenter le nombre
d'entreprises et sportatrices Paris
tenue Paris gagné on en était à 123.000
entreprises exportatrices en 2017 on en
est à 144000 + 21000 et donc c'est 17%
de croissance et tient d'ailleurs la vie
est bien faite on est à 18%
d'augmentation également des
exportations alors il y a une part prix
bien sûr mais il y a également une part
liée à ces nouveaux exportateurs et ce
qu'il faut c'est travailler au fait que
et bien c'est exportateurs le fassent
pas un coup mais de façon assez assez
répétée d'où le rôle des veille
j'insiste là dessus
variable école d'application de l'export
c'est volontaires internationaux pour
pour l'export d'où le rôle également de
cette TFE team France Export je veux
saluais l'engagement des régions de
business France dcci à l'international
de BPI des conseils du commerce
extérieur naturellement sans oublier les
osci et nos ambassadeurs parce que très
clairement là il y a une dynamique qui
s'est mise en place et qui permettra de
continuer à aller de l'avant parce qu'il
va falloir faire encore plus et encore
mieux dans la mesure où les exportations
niveau mondiales croisent plus vite que
les expressions françaises et donc notre
part de marché elle a tendance à se
réduire troisième point à mon avis à
relever c'est que nous devons continuer
à avoir une politique commerciale
particulièrement exigeante vis-à-vis de
nos partenaires la fois partenaires
européens et partenaire internationaux
réciprocité souveraineté c'était encore
il y a quelques années des gros mots
dans les couloirs les antichantes
bruxelloises je me résoudre les choses
est quand même évolué pour mettre plus
d'équité dans un certain nombre d'accord
et notamment commerciaux en juin 22 les
ministres agricultures sont tombées
d'accord sur justement l'idée des
clauses miroirs mais très clairement il
faut aussi que la partie commerce de la
commission prennent en compte tout cela
parce qu'un certain nombre d'accord
modernisés qui sont dites nouvelles
générations mais qui sont pas d'une
génération assez nouvelle pour nous
française je le dis très clairement il
faut être encore plus volontariste de
cette façon là pour que nos normes
deviennent des normes non pas seulement
européennes mais des normes qui
s'imposent au niveau mondial
quatrième point peut-être beaucoup
d'orateurs ont insisté également
là-dessus auparavant la nécessaire
relocalisation d'activités industrielles
et la planification que France 2030
permet c'est vrai que posk covid on voit
un ajustement dans les chaînes de valeur
c'est relocalisation qui sont à l'oeuvre
et pour lesquels d'ailleurs
effectivement le gouvernement mais
beaucoup d'impulsion on a parlé des
microprocesseurs on peut parler aussi
des membranes d'électrolyseur pour
produire l'hydrogène des carbonée
bientôt qui se feront en France et puis
l'attractivité du site France à travers
un certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
prises depuis plusieurs années sans être
naïf parce que les investissements il
faut aussi regarder qui sont les
investisseurs d'où le filtrage
nécessaire aussi pour un certain nombre
d'investissements stratégiques et puis
on est dans un monde de réréganisation
des échanges il faut le dire et de ce
point de vue là nous avons aussi la
force de d'un certain nombre de filiales
françaises établis à l'étranger et donc
le made in France doit être aussi
complété par le made France si je puis
dire tous ces entrepreneurs français
établir de France Les Français de
l'étranger qui participent aussi et bien
à leur façon à notre présence à
l'international qui est très différente
de nos amis allemands ou italiens et
puis enfin pour avoir une vue complète
les services qui sont un vrai atout le
tourisme on le voit et donc un sol des
transactions courantes qui est qui était
positif en 2021 et qui sans le
renchérissement de la facture
énergétique de 2022 serait encore plus
positif de l'or x 2 à 17 milliards
d'euros et donc comme j'arrive presque
au bout de mon temps je laisserai le
ministre répondre pour reprendre la
parole et HP mon propos madame la
Présidente
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur d'abord je voudrais
rendre hommage au travail que vous avez
effectué lorsque vous étiez au ministère
à ma place pour le lancement de la team
France Export parce que ce que vous avez
dit est très juste si aujourd'hui nous
avons une vraie dynamique notamment qui
permet d'accompagner nos entreprises
davantage à l'exportation c'est parce
que nous avons su rassembler les acteurs
à savoir business France les chambres de
commerce et d'industrie
l'abpi les régions qui gèrent le guichet
unique et derrière également d'autres
acteurs que sont les conseils du
commerce extérieur de la France les Esci
et bien d'autres nous avons su les
rassembler et les faire travailler en
équipe là où souvent ils étaient plutôt
en compétition les uns avec les autres
et donc c'est une très bonne nouvelle la
team France c'est une vraie réussite ça
marche deuxième point les Veilleux c'est
un vrai succès également il y a eu un
petit creux évidemment au cours de la
crise sanitaire parce que les frontières
étaient fermées et certains pays étaient
tout simplement inaccessibles
aujourd'hui la très bonne nouvelle c'est
que les affaires ont repris si je puis
me permettre et nous avons 1000 départs
de vieux par mois par mois donc ça aussi
c'est une situation extrêmement
favorable qui nous laisse penser que
nous allons là aussi avoir des succès
futurs avec nos entreprises qui se
portent à l'international et puis le
dernier point c'est pour dire évidemment
que je partageais totalement l'ambition
du made by France c'est j'ai absolument
pas d'encourager la délocalisation il
s'agit de reconnaître les entreprises
françaises de l'étranger qui participe
au rayonnement de notre pays et je
souhaite que l'on puisse arriver
un concept dans le cadre de la marque
France Merci monsieur Lemoine merci
Monsieur le Ministre merci beaucoup
pour suivre et terminer
que on peut en termes d'accompagnement
micro auprès des PME effectivement en
conforter le rôle de la TFE vous avez
lancé les ambassadeurs et c'est très
bien je veux dire aussi le rôle des
salons très important à la fois les
salons en France et les salons hors de
France très important d'aider les
entreprises à y aller de faire venir les
acheteurs internationaux et pour ça ben
voilà il faut effectivement des crédits
et puis dire que il y a aussi ce beau
projet des vitrines je sais un jeu de
pierre de Roissy que porte Evelyne
Renaud regarde et Jean-Pierre Bansart
tout ce qui permet de mettre en avant ce
made in France ou se mettre by France et
bienvenue et puis enfin ayant cet état
d'esprit conquérant une véritable
démarche d'intelligence économique c'est
un sujet cher également à Marie-Noël
linmann et tout ça me fait dire que 2022
a peut-être le goût d'une bataille
perdue mais que on va mener les combats
à venir et que la guerre économique on
la gagnera je parle de guerre économique
parce que c'est bien le climat actuel
dans les rations commerciales
merci la parole est à Madame Florence se
blatrix compta pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste républicain pour 5 minutes
chers collègues
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cela a été
dit la balance commerciale de la France
est en déficit chronique depuis 2002
déficit devenu abyssal ces dernières
années et pire au sein de l'Union
européenne la France se classe en queue
de Plotton puisque nous avions le plus
fort nous avions le plus fort déficit en
2021 donc la délégation aux entreprises
dans son rapport à tenter d'éclairer le
sujet d'avancer des propositions et je
remercie le président Babari de nous
permettre de débattre ce soir de ce
rapport au combien stratégique pour
notre économie je voudrais donc
m'attacher maintenant au nom des
sénateurs socialistes écologistes et
républicains à souligner quelques-uns
des aspects qui nous semblent importants
cela a été dit la dégradation des
performances de notre commerce extérieur
et le fruit de la désindustrialisation
de notre pays en atteste les données
récentes qu'à relever notre collègue
Marie-Noëlle linman sur la part de
l'industrie manufacturière dans le PIB
qui a été évalué à 9% qui est passé sous
la barre des 10%
et qui nous relègue là aussi dans les
tréfonds du classement européen et si on
va à l'intérieur puisque j'aurais pas
une vision au cirrhose que mon précédent
collègue sur le
notre commerce extérieur parce que on a
quand même des points très négatifs
l'automobile au début des années 2000 on
avait un excédent dans ce secteur on a
aujourd'hui un déficit de 18 milliards
les autres biens industriels le déficit
était d'une dizaine de milliards au
début des années 2000 on était à l'année
dernière à 66 milliards l'aéronautique
quant à elle n'a pas retrouvé sa
dynamique d'avant crise et il nous reste
bien que le secteur du luxe est des
cosmétiques qui semblent progresser
c'est quand même très inquiétant on peut
toutefois se rassurer en évoquant la
balance des services qui excédentaire
qui ne parvient pas à combler le déficit
de grandissant des biens et on peut
craindre pour l'avenir parce que si la
production de bien a été
délocalisée celle des services enfin
certains services pourront l'être à
l'avenir et par ailleurs le rapport
montre que le exportation de bien et de
services sont intimement liés et donc
face à cette dégradation continue il
faut réagir et cela a été évoqué par
plusieurs collègues à partir d'une
analyse stratégique sérieuse il faut
interroger nos choix de spécialisation
et analyser nos avantages comparatifs
dans un environnement certes incertain
il nous faudra construire des avantages
comparatifs porteurs pour l'avenir donc
collègues de la commission des affaires
économiques ont déterminé 5 plans
principaux pour reconstruire notre
souveraineté économique en France en
Europe et c'est une piste qu'il faut à
mon avis approfondir et mettre en oeuvre
donc cette vision stratégique de moyen
terme nous devons la construire et si la
compétitivité prix n'est pas à négligée
elle doit bien entendu pendant compte la
compétitivité hors prix notamment
l'innovation et le capital humain
la recherche constante de l'innovation
tendre les produits que dans les process
est une dimension essentielle de la
compétitivité est le tournant des
transitions numériques et écologiques
doit être pris en effet alors où le
changement climatique et la transition
énergétique qui l'implique percute nos
cas traditionnels de pensée notre
système productif une seconde
transformation est alors la numérisation
et la digitalisation et donc ces
transitions écologiques et numérique
auront un impact sur les formes des
échanges économiques et sur la
mondialisation et donc c'est dans ce
nouveau contexte global qu'il nous faut
désormais penser le commerce extérieur
ce sont ces éléments qui doivent devenir
demain des leviers de la compétitivité
de l'économie française et européenne
donc monsieur le ministre est-ce que les
services comment les services
ministériels travaillent-ils sur une
feuille de route géographique
sectorielle pour anticiper ce que seront
demain les échanges économiques dans le
monde et donc notre commerce extérieur
alors qu'on envisage partout et ça a été
peu soulevé dans le débat mais on
envisage partout et dans de nombreux
domaines des circuits courts et des
relocalisations donc quel commerce
extérieur dans ce cadre-là comment
construire de nouveaux avantages
comparatifs qui allient compétitivité et
ambition climatique et concernant la
campagne des l'accompagnement des
entreprises alors qu'un récent rapport
de la Cour des comptes monte les limites
de la stratégie de business France
comment allez-vous faire évoluer les
actions de business France et enfin
comment envisagez-vous la place de nos
PME ETI dans la nouvelle donne du
commerce mondial je vous remercie merci
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
juste peut-être de nuancer sur votre
propos en ce qui concerne des grands
secteurs exportateurs nous avons des
grands secteurs qui continuent à avoir
des excédents majeurs c'est le cas de
l'aéronautique c'est le cas de la
pharmacie c'est le cas de
l'agroalimentaire c'est le cas des
cosmétiques c'est le cas de la
construction navale encore 3 milliards
d'excédents cette année donc nous avons
la chance d'avoir en France des
champions des très grands groupes qui
sont des champions mondiaux et qui
portent ces exportations la faiblesse
de nos exportations françaises c'est que
derrière c'est très grand groupe qui
porte à peu près avec les ETI
80-7% des exp française
nos PME PMI elles ne portent que 13% de
nos exportations et c'est là que nous
devons porter véritablement le combat
parce que c'est là que nous avons des
marges de manœuvre importante en ce qui
concerne la feuille de route sectorielle
elle existe et elle est portée par
France 2030 ce sont les priorités de
France 2030 ce sont les grands secteurs
de croissance des prochaines décennies
dans lesquelles nous devons investir
pour faire en sorte que les industries
que nous développons à travers France
2030 soit aussi des entreprises
exportatrices et ensuite sur la question
géographique
bien sûr l'analyse existe mais comme je
dis souvent aux entreprises je ne veux
pas les restreindre dans leur choix
géographique pourquoi parce que le
slogan qu'elle devrait avoir c'est avoir
le monde que l'horizon il y a des grands
des des grands secteurs de croissance
aujourd'hui l'Asie demain l'Afrique très
certainement mais enfin ne pas obligé
non plus l'Amérique latine il faut que
pour une entreprise
enfin qui soit performante à l'export il
faut impérativement qu'elle est demain
le monde que l'horizon merci merci
monsieur le ministre le monde comme
horizon certes mais je crois que c'était
un élément soulevé par la Cour des
comptes dans le dans son récent en
rapport sur notamment l'accompagnement à
l'export que ce ne sont pas forcément
les pays qui seraient les plus
stratégiques qui sont les mieux dans
lesquels nos entreprises sont les mieux
accompagnées donc je pense qu'on a quand
même un vrai sujet à retravailler
là-dessus et compris sur la
sectorisation il faudrait pas qu'on rate
quand même les secteurs porteurs de
demain je pense on entend beaucoup
parler en ce moment de chat chipiti mais
de l'intelligence artificielle du cloud
souverain qui est devenu un Cloud de
confiance il faut vraiment qu'on ait des
ambitions dans ces domaines là je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Monsieur
Michel Canevet pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 4 minutes
bien Madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les madame les
rapporteurs chers collègues le groupe de
l'Union centriste tient à remercier la
délégation sénatoriale aux entreprises
d'avoir mené un travail sur cette
question essentielle du commerce
extérieur et aux trois rapporteurs
d'avoir justement formulé 10
propositions qui doivent permettre
d'améliorer la situation parce que la
situation monsieur le ministre cela a
été dit par les précédents orateurs à la
tribune elle n'est pas elle n'est pas
très bonne il faut reconnaître avec 164
milliards de déficit en 2022 de la
balance commerciale française donc une
augmentation très significative c'est
quasiment le doublement et et bien sûr
la facture énergétique n'est pas la
seule raison de cette
augmentation extrêmement significative
elle explique une partie de l'importance
du montant mais pas seulement et ceci
interroge d'ailleurs sur la stratégie
énergétique que nous pouvons avoir sur
notre pays mais
monsieur le ministre le groupe de
l'Union centriste estime que ce n'est
pas une fatalité qu'il faut
effectivement que nous prenions les
sujets abral corps pour arriver à
formuler des propositions alors les
propositions on les a vu il y a
notamment la première proposition qui
porte sur une loi d'orientation sur les
questions de commerce extérieur nous
pensons effectivement au niveau du
groupe de l'Union centriste qu'il est
important que la feuille de route soit
particulièrement bien tracée bien
définie que nous puissions la définir
ensemble c'est ainsi que le Parlement
doit bien sûr être mobilisé sur le sujet
c'est je crois l'une des propositions
importantes qu'ils font et nous
souscrivons totalement à cela car si les
objectifs de développement ne sont pas
partagés par l'ensemble de ceux qui sont
les acteurs de l'économie et les acteurs
politiques de notre pays je crois que
nous comprends pas au bout de nos peines
il faut dire que on a eu l'exemple de la
pandémie ou beaucoup d'acteurs se sont
mobilisés pour produire des masques par
exemple dans d'autres pays Vincent
Segoin dans son propos liminaire il a
évoqué tout à l'heure
et puis le résultat qu'on a observe
aujourd'hui c'est que la plupart de ces
opérateurs sont dans la panade
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui nous avons
repris nos vieilles habitudes de
recourir aux offres les moins chères les
moins chers c'est bien entendu souvent
ce qui vient de chez d'autres pays enfin
d'Asie et donc tous les opérateurs qui
en France se sont mobilisés pour
apporter des réponses nationales se
retrouvent dans la difficulté et ceci
n'est pas acceptable donc il importe que
nous puissions apporter des des réponses
les réponses seront aussi notamment par
une action continue sur la compétitivité
de nos entreprises beaucoup pas été fait
est engagés par le gouvernement à ce
sujet sur la baisse des charges il faut
que l'on continue et je ne partage pas
les opinions qui tout à l'heure ont été
émis sur la gauche
par des orateurs sur le fait que il
failli arrêter la baisse des charges non
il faut qu'on poursuive et en
particulier qu'on puisse même les
prolonger parce qu'ils concernent les
charges sociales qui constituent un
handicap dans la compétitivité donc si
nous pouvons travailler là-dessus et je
formulerai des propositions dans le
cadre du débat sur la retraite pour
pouvoir substituer les charges sociales
à une autre ressource bien entendu et
donc on voit qu'il y a beaucoup à faire
là dessus voilà donc et puis il y a sans
doute monsieur le ministre un travail
plus approfondi en synergie à mener avec
l'ensemble des opérateurs je veux par
exemple parler des régions que la
compétence économique je suis de
Bretagne nous avons Bretagne commerce
international en région mais il faut pas
que Bretagne commerce international
travaille dans son coin il faut qu'il y
ait une stratégie nationale bien définie
qui soit élaboré ensemble et ceci doit
être le cas dans tous les régions merci
de votre attention merci chers collègues
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs sur
le sénateur
j'ai déjà je pense répondu à beaucoup de
points qui
structurer votre propos
j'aimerais peut-être juste faire
une assise sur la question de la loi de
programmation qui est effectivement fait
partie des très bonnes propositions qui
sont incluses dans le rapport je ne sais
pas s'il faut une loi de programmation
on est dans un domaine où les choses
évoluent quand même très rapidement on
le voit aujourd'hui avec une fashion
réduction Act américain qui vient en
plus d'un allié
traditionnel de l'Europe et
particulièrement de pays en revanche qui
est certain c'est qu'il faut une
stabilité
des dispositifs et des mécanismes et ça
je crois je ne sais pas s'ils sont
inscrits dans une loi de programmation
mais en tout cas si on veut
véritablement relever le challenge à la
fois de la réindustrialisation et celui
de porter de PME PMI à l'exportation on
a besoin de dispositif stable visible
clair et ça je crois que c'est le
véritable enjeu sur lequel nous devons
aujourd'hui nous engager merci
Monsieur canevêque oui merci monsieur le
ministre vous savez bien relevé
effectivement que c'était l'une des
propositions importantes qu'il faut que
l'on soutiennent la loi de programmation
a néanmoins l'objectif de mobiliser tout
le monde autour de d'ambition forte pour
notre pays parce que c'est ça qui est
important il y a bien sûr les acteurs
économiques qui sont les principaux
opérateurs mais on le voit bien qu'il y
a un grand nombre d'intervenants
aujourd'hui sur le sujet et que tout le
monde n'est pas dans le même ordre de
fonctionnement et donc c'est c'est
vraiment par cette mobilisation je crois
par cette loi la mobilisation de tous
que l'on puisse définir là où sont les
priorités et que les acteurs sur le
terrain puissent savoir dès lors vers où
aller et sur quel soutien ils pourront
compter pour pouvoir continuer à
mais comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
aussi la baisse des charges doit se
poursuivre et elle est engagée merci
[Applaudissements]
le ministre madame messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues les chiffres
le relatifs au commerce extérieur sont
catastrophiques je ne les reprendrai pas
ici puisque mes collègues en ont parlé
tout à l'heure face à cela les plans des
gouvernements successifs les rapports
parlementaires et je tiens à saluer la
qualité de votre rapport n'ont
absolument pas inversé la tendance en
partie car nous n'avons pas appliqué les
recommandations en partie car nous
dépendons des mouvements internationaux
en partie enfin car nous n'avons pas la
culture de l'export comme vous l'a dit
monsieur le ministre c'est en réalité
sur dernier point qui à mon sens prend
le dessus sur tout le reste je ne
reviendrai pas sur les variables macro
et microéconomique du commerce extérieur
le rapport le fait très bien je voudrais
revenir sur un seul aspect qui est
précisément la façon d'envisager le
commerce extérieur qui passe en premier
lieu par l'étranger nous avons de
grandes entreprises françaises qui
exportent sans l'aide de l'État elle
connaissent les pays les dirigeants
ainsi que les chefs d'entreprise elles
font leur propre réseau nous n'avons
jamais compté autant d'exportateurs
français depuis 20 ans ils sont près de
140 000 les traditionnelles locomotives
Airbus ou LVMH et les grandes
entreprises de constituent de manière
étonnante que
0,5% des exportateurs pourtant elle pèse
pour 52% de leur valeur les PME PMI et
TPE qui je le rappelle constitue la
majorité du tissu économique français
représente plus de 99% des troupes à
l'export mais malheureusement
seulement 48% de la valeur bien que de
très nombreuses entreprises à l'export
performante dans leur secteur respectifs
souvent de niche elle n'exporte que de
façon très ponctuelle faute par elle de
maîtriser les règles de l'export elles
ne sont pas anglophones elles ne se
déplacent pas elle ne communique pas
l'international et elles n'ont pas de
stratégie globale à l'export elle
constitue pourtant Monsieur le Ministre
la vitrine de la France ce sont elles
qui ont besoin de nous pour augmenter
leur chiffre d'affaires à l'export notre
objectif doit donc être d'aider nos PME
et PMI à généraliser l'exportation pour
y parvenir il faut développer une réelle
culture de l'export auprès des étudiants
des futurs chefs d'entreprise avec des
formations spécifiques il faut que les
PME PMI considèrent que l'international
est une clé dans leur développement au
même titre que le marché intérieur il
faut faire la promotion des outils
d'accompagnement à l'export et renforcer
la coordination des acteurs business
France BPI France les régions je
rappelle que la Cour des comptes a
publié en octobre 2022 un rapport et a
constaté que ses acteurs se trouvaient
dans une situation de concurrence entre
et non malheureusement de coopération il
faut davantage s'appuyer sur une
diplomatie économique parallèle que nous
n'exploitons absolument pas les
entrepreneurs français installés à
l'étranger je ne parle pas des
entreprises françaises installées à
l'étranger mais bien des entrepreneurs
qui ont créé une entreprise de droit
local nous avons dans tous les pays du
monde des entrepreneurs français ces
personnes sont françaises apportent des
produits et des services français dans
leur pays de résidence ils connaissent
l'économie locale comme personne les
marchés qu'il faut exploiter et ce qu'il
faut éviter ce créer une entreprise ce
sont eux qui ont construit et établi des
connexions avec les acteurs économiques
locaux je suis chef d'entreprise et
sénateurs français de l'étranger en
contact permanent avec ces entrepreneurs
français qui participent au rayonnement
de la France et qui peuvent être des
puissants relais de croissance à double
égard d'une part en facilitant l'export
des entreprises je viens d'en parler
longuement d'autre part on importe
massivement des produits et des services
français dans leur pays de résidence
nous devons soutenir ces entreprises
pour eux la France Monsieur le Ministre
est une marque qu'il vende ce que les
géants du luxe ont d'ailleurs très bien
compris il n'y a pas un pays au monde
vous ne trouverez pas une référence à
Paris ou une reproduction de la Tour
Eiffel d'une baguette ou d'un camembert
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
voudrais parler du projet de la belle
Mike by France déjà évoquée par notre
collègue et qui vendent et à l'étranger
des produits et des services français ce
label vise à valoriser la fabrication ou
la conception française des produits des
services leurs qualités leur origine le
savoir fait français artisanal ou
industriel le respect des normes le
terroir en un mot l'excellence
françaises ces entrepreneurs constituent
le réseau des Chambres de Commerce
France International 120 chambres dans
94 pays sans aucune aide publique nous
ne les valorisons pas suffisamment or le
réseau c'est la base de tout projet
entrepreneurial seul nous ne faisons
rien ces chambres devraient être une
partie essentielle de toute démarche
visant notre balance commerciale je
soutiens l'ensemble des recommandations
du rapport de mes collègues en insistant
sur le rôle que pourrait avoir au sein
d'une stratégie du commerce extérieur
efficace les entrepreneurs français à
l'étranger d'autre part d'autres l'ont
bien compris qui valorisent bien plus
que nous le potentiel économique de leur
diaspora je parle ici de la Chine je
présenterai dans quelques semaines une
proposition de loi visant à valoriser
nos entrepreneurs français cela n'est
pas seulement dans leur intérêt c'est
dans l'intérêt de notre commerce
extérieur c'est dans l'intérêt de la
France la bataille de l'export se
gagnant pour moi d'abord à l'étranger
merci de votre écoute merci chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre c'est comme vous
voulez vous pouvez commencer et puis
faire votre propos après
bien sûr
ça madame
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice je voulais vous dire
que je partageais totalement votre
engagement en ce qui concerne les
entreprises françaises
à l'étranger
nous avons les entrepreneurs français de
l'étranger nous avons besoin d'eux pour
le rayonnement de notre pays ce sont
également des acteurs et des supports
pour de paix l'exportation française et
je voulais également vous dire que je
partageais qu'il y a votre analyse sur
le rôle central que doivent avoir les
chambres de commerce françaises à
l'étranger nous avons mis en place un
pilotage fin de la team France Export
dans lequel nous avons inclus évidemment
les CCI françaises à l'étranger
et je l'ai réuni environ c'est il y a le
Conseil national de l'export mais qui ne
se réunissait à peu près fois par an là
je réunis l'ensemble des acteurs de la
team France Export tous les mois ou tous
les deux mois directement au ministère
pour faire le pilotage femme de ses
dossiers donc je voulais dire que je
partageais évidemment votre
préoccupation et l'analyse que vous
portez dans ce domaine merci merci
le ministre ces entrepreneurs français
vont être ravis de la réaction que vous
avez eu
j'insisterai sur quelque chose de savoir
si on pourrait envisager de discuter en
commun et de réfléchir éventuellement un
dispositif d'aide qui pourrait peut-être
intervenir merci de votre merci alors la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier belge ton
ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité des Français
de l'étranger pour 5 minutes
maximum
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
d'abord je voudrais rendre hommage à la
qualité du travail des parlementaires
qui se sont engagés dans ce rapport et
dire que évidemment je partage le
constat et nous le verrons une bonne
partie des propositions qu'ils mettent
aujourd'hui sur la table j'en profite
également puisque à l'Assemblée
nationale un rapport a aussi qui était
rendu la semaine dernière avec le député
Charles Rodwell pour rendre également
hommage à la qualité de ce travail et je
voulais vous remercier mesdames la
présidente d'avoir rendu ce débat
possible ici ce soir au Sénat le jour où
nous rendons publics les chiffres du
commerce extérieur de la France pour
l'année 2022 alors je voudrais
simplement parce que c'est une
précaution de langage qui me semble tout
de même
utile parce qu'on parle de déficit
commercial en parlant des 174 milliards
dire que en fait les 164 milliards c'est
la balance des biens et que le la
balance commerciale c'est aussi la
balance des revenus et la balance des
services et quand on regarde ces deux
autres balances on se rend compte que
autant la balance des biens a déficit
extrêmement important qui a doublé par
rapport à l'année dernière pour les
raisons qu'on a évoqué sur la question
énergétique mais lorsqu'on regarde
balance des services nous avons un
excédent qui lui est aussi un excédent
record puisque nous n'avons jamais eu
autant nous avons 50 milliards d'euros
dû à la reprise du tourisme du à la
dynamique de nos transports et dû
également au service financier puisque
nous bénéficions à la suite du brexit du
dynamisme de la place de Paris qui est
devenu il faut quand même le dire la
première place boursière en Europe en
matière de capitalisation par action
nous avons détrôné la City de temps à
autre il faut aussi entendre la forêt
poussée et pas simplement l'arbre tombé
donc pour dire que nous sommes bons dans
le domaine des services nous sommes
également bon dans le domaine des
revenus puisque toutes les grandes
entreprises qui travaillent et aussi
certaines entreprises françaises de
l'étranger qui travaillent à l'étranger
rapatrie également les revenus en France
30 milliards d'euros d'excédents c'est
quand même considérable et là aussi
c'est un record
par rapport aux Alliés précédentes et
aux dix années précédentes nous avions à
peu près 8 milliards en moyenne sur
cette balance alors après il ne faut pas
se satisfaire évidemment de cette
situation puisque sur la balance des
biens on est tout à fait d'accord on a
un vrai problème ce vrai problème il est
lié à l'énergie c'est conjoncturels nous
allons le résorber et il y a un problème
structurel qui est lié nous l'avons dit
dans le débat ce soir à la fois à la
désindustrialisation de notre pays que
nous avons vécu au cours des 30
dernières années et elle a faiblesse de
nos PME PMI à l'exportation comparé à
nos grands voisins et donc ce sont dans
ces domaines-là qu'il faut agir et qu'il
faut agir vite c'est la
réindustrialisation que nous avons
lancée avec le plan France 2030 54
milliards d'euros qui sont posés sur la
table avec des résultats qui sont déjà
visibles aujourd'hui parce que ce sont
des usines qui se construisent au lieu
d'usine qui ferme ce sont des emplois
industriels qui sont créés ce sont des
usines
dans les domaines stratégiques que sont
les semis conducteurs comme St
microélectronics acroll dans le domaine
de la pharmacie avec le paracétamol les
principes actifs avec l'usine séquence
dans l'Isère ce sont les usines qui se
montent également pour raffiner le
lithium que ce soit dans l'Allier ou
encore dans l'exploitation du lithium
dans le Bas-Rhin donc il y a de cela un
certain nombre de choses qui sont déjà
parties et qui sont positives et puis il
y a le dernier domaine qui est
évidemment celui sur lequel on doit agir
rapidement également puisque la
réindustrialisation prendra du temps
c'est la question évidemment de nos PME
PMI alors Monsieur Jean-Baptiste Lemoine
l'a rappelé tout à l'heure nous avons
déjà une satisfaction puisque nous avons
de plus en plus d'entreprises
exportatrices on est passé de 120 000 à
144 400 entreprises exportatrices
l'année dernière ça reste cependant
insuffisant par rapport à nos grands
voisins et donc il y a une culture de
l'exportation qui doit être inculqué
aujourd'hui c'est un combat mais c'est
un combat qui se mène aussi maître par
Maître en demandant aujourd'hui aux
acteurs de la team France Export et
particulièrement au conseiller des
chambres de commerce et d'industrie en
plus de ceux de business France d'aller
faire du porte-à-porte auprès de chaque
PME pour faire en sorte que l'on puisse
les aider à se projeter à l'exportation
sans coup de cas l'engagement que je
prends devant vous en tant que ministre
délégué en charge du commerce extérieur
et de l'attractivité c'est un combat que
nous pouvons gagner et c'est un combat
que nous gagnerons ensemble je vous
remercie
merci je me permets de vous remercier
monsieur le ministre d'avoir vraiment
fait le jeu de ce débat interactif en
répondant à tous les orateurs merci
merci beaucoup alors pour conclure le
débat la parole est à Monsieur Serge
babary président de la délégation
sénatoriale aux entreprises pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame monsieur les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues merci chacun d'avoir
participé
à ce débat je pense toujours intéressant
et
utile pour un tel sujet
les alertes du Sénat se sont multipliés
depuis plusieurs années pour faire
prendre conscience de notre dépendance
aux importations notamment celles
provenant d'Asie mon collègue va
s'engagin évoquait les ruptures
d'approvisionnement des médicaments s'il
y avait répondu je rappelle que la
commission des affaires économiques en
2018 déjà puis dans son rapport
présentant cinq plans pour reconstruire
la souveraineté économique souligner
cette dépendance en effet
l'approvisionnement de la France en
ingrédients pharmaceutique actif
provient à plus de 80% de Chine et
d'Inde
j'évoquais dans un débat précédent
aujourd'hui même le sujet des véhicules
électriques et le même constat de
dépendance aux importations asiatiques
peut être dressé dans le cas des
semi-conducteurs il y avait également
répondu or les travaux de mes collègues
de la délégation aux entreprises
montrent clairement que les études sur
les vulnérabilités les
approvisionnements de la France minimise
les risques encourus qu'il s'agisse des
publications de la direction générale du
Trésor ou du Conseil d'analyse
économique elle s'appuie sur des données
qui ne permettent pas de distinguer les
différents intrants de la chaîne de
valeur des biens importés ainsi par
exemple un bien importé d'Allemagne
n'est pas jugé risqué car il est
identifié comme provenant de l'Union
européenne même s'il dépend de
composants importés exclusivement de
Chine
il me semble monsieur le ministre que
nous ne pouvons plus nous contenter
d'une analyse qui minimise autant les
risques alors que les récentes crises
ont montré aux Français les conséquences
des délocalisations massives de nos
sites de production il faut mobiliser la
Commission européenne pour que les
données des États membres permettent
d'appréhender collectivement la réelle
dépendance de nos économies européennes
comme souvent il existe un décalage
entre la perception de l'administration
de l'État et la réalité économique vécue
sur le terrain par les entreprises et
les citoyens cette même déconnexion est
ressentie par les entreprises face à la
complexité des normes qui leur sont
applicables elles ne cessent de se
multiplier au point de détourner les
dirigeants de leur cœur de métier et
plomber notre compétitivité en matière
de commerce extérieur nous l'avons vu en
Italie en Allemagne les ETI sont un
véritable atout pourtant en France comme
le mouvement des entreprises de taille
intermédiaire le rappeler récemment
devant notre délégation 700 nouvelles
normes s'impose aux et chaque année
chaque année en plus du stock de 400 000
normes existantes ce qui représente un
coût total de 28 milliards d'euros pour
nous et la simplification des normes est
un enjeu central pour le commerce
extérieur et je ne doute pas que vous
suivrez avec attention les conclusions
de notre mission d'information
actuellement en cours sur le sujet au
sein de notre délégation on vous fera
part de nos conclusions le redressement
du commerce extérieur dépendra des
efforts déployés par chaque ministère
chaque acteur public ou privé de
l'écosystème les grandes entreprises
devront apprendre à chasser en meute
avec les PME les acheteurs publics
devront prendre exemple sur nos voisins
européens et dépasser le critère du
moindre coût pour ne plus défavoriser
les TPE et PME françaises bref nous
avons tous un rôle à jouer
la désindustrialisation a produit un
cercle vicieux car nous n'avons pas su
ou pas voulu en mesurer les conséquences
dans tous les domaines ayant un impact
sur notre compétitivité chômage
endémique affaiblissement de nos
compétences et l'innovation ça a été
rappelé il nous faut désormais nous
doter d'une structure capable de piloter
efficacement notre stratégie ce que nous
proposons avec la rénovation du conseil
stratégique de l'export le gouvernement
doit enfin entendre l'appel du
législateur qui réclame depuis longtemps
de véritables études d'impact en amont
des projets de loi prenant en compte
tous les effets des politiques publiques
qu'il s'agissent de formation de
fiscalité ou de normes environnementales
il est temps de permettre aux
entreprises de développer leur talent à
l'étranger mais aussi dans nos
territoires en leur offrant enfin un
écosystème favorable je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
alors mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
22h05 pour le débat sur les conclusions
du rapport compétitivité une urgence
pour redresser la ferme France et la
séance est suspendue
[Musique]